hey everybody
the ride just gets wilder and wilder and
this week
we have got a legend of big wave
surfing and just all-around badassery
so let's get to it
ladies and gentlemen laird hamilton
yeah dude i want you to meet my co-host
scott randolph how you doing
hi scott aloha coming from off camera
for
for you the gorgeous paul briskey hello
hilary
paul how you doing speeding take chances
yeah dude
it's uh it's it's an honor to have you
man thank you for doing this
and i can proudly tell you that i do not
believe there is a single one of these
podcasts
where i have not been drinking coffee
which was
chock full of your laird hamilton
superfood creamer well i'll i'll uh i'll
send you a case i do i send you one
anyway but i'll get you
we'll get you a case of that stuff dude
we go through it
at such an alarming rate and i had
countless
friends of mine our buddy tommy hadn't
drank
yeah he relapsed off coffee after like
five years because of it
yeah right we got everybody that's not a
bad thing
that's not a bad thing if you're going
to do it do if you're going to do it do
it right you know
we got to get you this machine i have a
machine that uh
makes everything you just push the
button it's kind of good and bad
it makes a perfect cut but it makes it a
little too convenient okay
so you just have coffee all day that's
the secret well yeah you
just never need to eat or anything dude
i think i need that really badly because
i have like
uh i don't even know if it's a growing
tolerance but i just have a progressing
addiction
where i pile in more coffee more and
more of this layered creamer i know like
it's
it can't be healthy like how much of it
i'm consuming i dump it in until i'm
thinking like oh god and then i dump a
little more
[Laughter]
i love it how'd you come up with that
hey i want to just tell you
congratulations
to for you know being alive thank you
that's a big deal yeah you got a good
job you survived
to a point where you're actually sitting
down with a remote control because
that's good
ah dude it's honorable it's an honorable
deed it's a tough journey down here you
know
hard to oh man i appreciate that so much
man
i mean it yeah life is really good dude
i never
would have thought that i would be alive
past
30. i never expected to make it 2 30.
but if you asked me at any point like
you know what what what would life
look like for you at age 46
i would just probably get bummed out
like i did i got and here i am
thriving it's really killer man how old
are you
i'm 56 so i got you by 10. i got i got
10 on you
i mean it's inspiring it's good to have
people like that to look up to
it dude it's unbelievable i've always
said that that uh
but before i got sober tommy lee was my
little buffer zone i
i thought if he's still partying then
i've got 10 more years in me
and then i got sober and i started
looking to tony hawk you know if tony
hawk's still getting rad
then i got seven more years in me six
more years
but dude like you're totally getting rat
right like
best i can best that you you know the
thing the truth is is that you to
to really continue to be able to push
stuff you got to be healthy you got to
be you got to be
straight you i mean you just got to be
yeah you have to be sober to really
deal especially now with all the stuff
going on i mean
being in this world right now if in
a clear state that would be rough
i've gotten really into uh ice baths and
saunas
and and i can totally tell the
difference you know after i
after i do them but when did you start
doing ice baths or when did the light
bulb go off for you that like it's
it's pretty important you know i i had a
uh
i've been i was exposed to a couple
people when i was younger like one guy
was a sauna
like a just a sauna freak and he would
just live in the sauna and he had had
some health
issues but it was like the thing that
was keeping him kind of going and
he would do eucalyptus and all kinds of
oils and do that so i was exposed to
that and then
a hockey uh player friend of mine this
guy chris celios
he was into sauna and he he attributed
that to like a career thing
and uh and then i always like cold water
like i'd be in europe somewhere in the
french alps and it'd be like a giant
river
and i just stripped down and go jump in
and you know of course everybody thinks
you're crazy but you just always felt
like like alive you come in that cold
water and you just get lit up and
so i knew kind of intuitively that those
environments were were healthy
and then uh probably the last i know
we're going on
probably 15 years of of you know good
solid 10 years of being in
you know consistent ice tubs and i mean
when you surf you're in cold water and
you're
you know i tell people i go listen
you're if you're in your surf shorts and
you're in hawaii and you serve for six
or eight hours and it's a cold winter
day
i mean you're as cold as you are in a
cold place with a wetsuit on like you're
you could be older just because of that
so i think it's been a
kind of a part of my life but not so not
so
uh you know just judiciously i mean i we
just we live with that stuff or
i'm signing multiple times a day i
incorporate
ice and sauna in my training um it's
just
it's a part of your life because you
feel you just start to feel like you
just don't feel right you kind of go
what's up i feel kind of i just feel
dirty and then you go take a sauna and
do an ice and you're like oh yeah back
to
back to the equilibrium and i got to get
on board dude it's
it's it's a game changer are you you're
doing it every day
i do you know ice i mean ice is a little
less inviting and if you're tired it
kind of hammers you but
i'll wake up early and do a sauna like
in the like today i was in there at like
4 35 a.m
and get hot and you know like people
talk about warming up it just takes any
stiffness
out of you so you get real loose and
then
uh and then just that and you know and
then i'll do them at night it affects
your sleep a lot
as well so i'm but i'm doing a sauna and
probably ice
probably ice five times a week and
saunas almost every day i mean
i'm in those things and then and then
i'll do both sometimes i'll just do like
on sunday
i'll go back and forth between the two
and do contrast but you know
there's a statistic that uh reduction
and you'll appreciate this reduction in
alzheimer's and dementia
by 65 if you do a sauna three to five
times a week
wow and my favorite my favorite one is
is reduction in
all cars mortality i think i thought you
might like that word that's one of my
favorite words all cause mortality
which means any way you can die is
reduced by 40 so you reduce
40 reduction in any way you can die i'm
not sure how that works out
sauna three to five times the you know
the sauna three to five times a week
that
that's uh but then there's all the
science behind it they're doing it for
uh depression so people are they're
starting they're doing a science study
on uh
the clinically depressed people and
they're running them through a protocol
of sauna
and you know i have friends that were
had some depression issues and they
start doing ice tubs three times a week
and they're like
depression has gone away you know yeah
it's like if you're clinically depressed
and like
you take an ice bath it's like you know
ask them if they're depressed they're
like what
like it'd be hard to be depressed
coming out of an ice bath ah i could
probably pull it off
um so you said that you're in the you
were in the french alps and i just
couldn't help but be curious what would
bring you to the french alps is that
surfing
no snowboard well obviously not the
ocean no ocean there but snowboarding
you know i was in europe and i was uh i
was there for windsurfing and
some crazy french guys told me hey you
know we want to take you up because they
heard that i like to do
you know helicopter skiing dangerous
stuff so then they're like okay well
we'll take you to the french alps and i
think it's like my third day or
something they were sending me off with
a
dumb down some giant run and i'm looking
down like where do you even go
and and the french guys are just yeah
you just go straight and i'm going well
then what and he goes well you just keep
going straight i'm like
so you just go and just go straight the
whole way like
sure i'll do it and just you know you
can relate yeah it's crazy that makes me
think of
uh tony hawk was telling us about being
with you
on some big waves i feel like yeah or
you you took tony out
like uh toe and surfing or something
with him and his brother
and his brother yeah him and his brother
it's great it's crazy because
you with the snowboard guys is probably
the equivalent of
tony with you right like sir yeah yeah
you're just a victim to me just you just
hope that the guys you're with
are going to be nice to you you know
what i mean because you don't know
because there might be like
hey this guy thinks he knows what he's
doing over here let's you know subject
him to like a cliff or something so you
you're kind of like hey you know like
can i
are these guys going to try to send me
into the wolves or
yeah it's like it's like when you're in
turbulence and you see a flight
attendant and like her face is straight
and you're like okay i'm cool
you know it's like people probably look
to you when they're surfing jaws or
something like that
yeah except for like in in that case if
the plane goes down you're both in the
same situation
in this case it's like tony drowns
laird's fine
plus if larry's not scared that's not
necessarily
negative right exactly it's like
manny the the shark guy you know
if he says it's cool that doesn't mean
[ __ ]
yeah yeah what is cool
yes now speaking of tony and surfing i'm
proud to tell you
that yesterday i rode out of my first
barrel
first time ever first time i ever rode
out of a barrel
and at kelly slater's surf ranch with
tony
yeah and and scott got the trophy for
the wave of the day
yeah that that they gave it to me in
part because uh when i
rode past them i was i was brushing my
mustache you know
i figured that would do get some points
that you were concerned about your
mustache you must have been
yeah i didn't want to get it wet he was
stroking his lip sweater
[Laughter]
yeah those things are dirty but i won't
go there
yeah dude so um now with the
the superfood creamer how long has that
been going on
um we're five years in right now so that
we've been that's been uh
five years and uh and we just actually
went public this year so we went
we went we went public so we were we're
on the uh
which who would ever thought you know
it's kind of like i bet you in your life
you never thought you could do all the
things you did you're going to be
sitting where you are
so right it's a little bit of that you
know it's a little bit of
it's a little bit of you know some fairy
dust along the way i would imagine
you know you can relate to it yeah for
sure the angels are helping out
i uh the first thing i thought when you
said that was [ __ ] i should [ __ ]
invest
you know it's crazy because there was
one
like i think only one episode of this
podcast was actually sponsored by
laird superfood creamer and uh you know
i demonstrated how much i pour into a
cup like
embarrassingly even because that's like
literally how i do it
but uh you know there was a bunch of um
packages that came where they just
supplied it to us and honestly candidly
i buy that [ __ ] on my own without it
being sent to me
and they carry it at my local cvs
and i routinely go in there and get
[ __ ] 10 big bags of it
at once and just burn through them it's
crazy well we got to get
we got to get you on the on the on the i
mean we i i think the cool thing too is
about the company is that we're
we're we're kind of doing it a little
bit modern because we're
a lot of it's online so a lot of what we
do is online and you have then you have
subscription
so people sign up and they just have you
know that that box that you buy that
thing just shows up like every two weeks
or something right when they're gonna
run out so
that's that's a uh that's a good thing
my
the friend of mine because we started it
you know somebody goes oh especially
athletes they're always like well how'd
those guys find you and
the whole thing and i'm like yeah it
wasn't really like that it was like i
was making these
coffees and then i shared it with a
buddy of mine and he uh and then he
he was like hey this stuff's incredible
what are you putting in here i gave him
the ingredients
and then he made like a couple
prototypes he made like a
three three or four different powdered
versions and then all of a sudden it was
like okay well that's the original
creamer so like
it was pretty it was pretty you know
like i said it wasn't a
i mean i've done some things where you
really thought about it and had made a
real plan and they flopped like you know
like a fish
and then this one was a little bit like
it wasn't a plan it wasn't anything
tricky unfortunately the guy that i was
sharing it with was it was like a
you know startup expert so he had been
through a bunch of things in fact him
and i were
working on that electric skateboard that
we had for the
golf so we had that electric golf board
and he helped us with that company and
then he tried the coffee and he was like
oh that stuff's awesome what do you know
what are you putting in it and then
that's where superfood came out of and
when it was that
original batch that you were making what
were you putting in there
speaking of putting things in here we
are on a big old tour bus which i rented
for my crew to go on a secret
mission and they got it all in here six
beds
huge kitchen with a stove oven microwave
big old fridge but you know what they
didn't put in here
a bidet from hellotushy.com
and i'm telling you it's my favorite
product i've ever promoted on this
podcast when i get done taking a big old
sloppy dump
i really love to be able to twist the
knob
for that refreshing adjustable stream
which blasts my butthole nice and clean
yeah dude i mean i love road trips
just hate being away from my hello tushy
and if you don't have one then you don't
know what i'm talking about
and it's time for you to get it because
i don't throw around
my favorite at all i've only ever said
it about hellotushy.com
so go to hellotushy.com stevo
for 10 off your order and free shipping
again you are crazy if you haven't tried
this yet
so support the podcast support your
butthole
and go to hellotushy.como
for 10 off your order and free shipping
now let's find
out what goes in i never liked uh
there's a guy named paul check um who
you guys may or may not know of and he
said he's the guy that used to
uh mend danny way when he put benny wait
yeah he told us about him actually so
every time he wanted to break
another guy back in san diego send him
yeah you know so paul checked paul check
and i paul was the espresso lover
him and i were drinking ghee we were
using ghee in express so we were doing
that probably i want to say 15 or 20
years ago i
you know i because of my french habits
uh
red wine was one of them but expresso
was done so i've been a coffee
fanatic and then i started putting ghee
in it and then i heard and then the guys
were talking about butter and i'm like
what's the difference between cream and
butter and ghee
and then coconut oil so so everything
was all whole food based so my original
recipe was
was coconut oil and some other other
oils
from some other palm stuff and uh
and so and i made like i said i had a
concoction that i would make that i'd
put
different things in we're putting some
minerals in or some you know we got
those performance mushrooms
i'm just using i was just using coffee
as like a as like a platform to put a
bunch of good
nutrients and then we started realizing
that when you eat
food with fat you absorb more nutrients
and that's why you do stuff like
put butter on vegetables and olive oil
on a salad it's all about
nutrient absorption and so the body's
getting the brain wants the fat so
the body pulls it in and then you get
the nutrients so it's
it ended up just being a really great
place to start and
and and plenty of people drink coffee
and put a lot of garbage in it so it was
a real opportunity to
kind of help people get out of there you
know
all that refined sugar and all that
other stuff that's more probably better
for painting houses
get that out and get them some real
stuff and so that's really the
but that was the basis of it now like i
said i had a a recipe because i've been
playing with ghee and then
and then the bulletproof guy had the
butter uh one but we were like we were
already using ghee so we were pretty
comfortable with
the butter concept and then coconut oil
being from hawaii i drink coconut water
and
grew up on that stuff so we were coconut
friendly
and and it just it like i said it all
kind of came naturally from
you know from uh just stuff that i've
been exposed to and kind of
you know you know how it is it all kind
of comes together and you're like wow
i didn't think that those things were
going to influence that other stuff
but it's so great he says uh coffee as a
platform
to like get other stuff and i thought
it's like
yeah like i use french fries as a shovel
for ketchup
but if you had a good really good potato
and you were shoveling some really good
other things then that probably wouldn't
be that bad so we're just trying to
keep you with your french fries you can
keep your french fries but let's make
the french fries better and let's make
what you're dipping them
in better right can you make laird's
superfood ketchup for me
because hey well dad don't don't don't
don't
uh put a pass that's probably not that's
probably i mean
like i said those are the things that we
look for opportunities right because in
a way
there's so many things out there that
people are consuming that probably
aren't bad
if we can just get them the quality
stuff it's just that
you know money making has made it so we
don't care what we put in it so we put a
bunch of garbage in there and then we
wonder why people aren't
feeling well right larry do you have any
vices like i feel like
every part of your whole program is just
on point like is there anything that i
am a vice
you know like i like like my go
my wife gabby always talks about the dog
with the bone you know once i get to
something i'm just like i don't
i think that's probably i mean obviously
coffee i love
i mean i look at coffee as probably one
of my one of my uh
you know one of my great vices i mean
that's the thing that i really enjoy i
enjoy it
so and i i believe that if you're doing
something every day it's probably good
to try to do it with the highest quality
you can like if you're gonna
whatever you're doing if you need french
fries then make sure the potatoes are
good
they're cooked in good stuff and that
you know so because it
can some you know you're putting food
you're putting things in your body
that's not
the place to try to save money and skimp
on ingredients i think that's right you
know you can wear
ugly shoes you know you can wear some
bad shoes and get a bad shirt and all
that stuff but stuff you're consuming
toothpaste soap i mean just all those
stuff that you use every day
because that stuff over time is
accumulative right
you just start to accumulate the
negativity or the positivity
you know from it so i mean one of the
things that you don't realize evo is
that we put this calcified c algae in
that
in the creamers so the minerals that
you're getting are some of the most
bioavailable minerals and
and the fact is that most of our food is
mineral short like where most of the
food that we eat
doesn't have the minerals because we
don't fertilize like we used to and all
that stuff so
in a way you know that's all part that's
so i'm actually
making you healthy but wait a second
laird i distinctly remember when i was a
kid
my fruity pebbles said they were
fortified with vitamins and minerals
yeah it just you couldn't absorb any of
them they were putting them in there
they were just going out that's funny i
remember a box of that [ __ ] was never
big enough
that's good oh man i crapped in crunch
man i used to get captain crunch yeah
and i'd smash it down
in the bowl and then pour the milk in
there my mom would come home there'd be
like
a half gallon milk would be gone she
goes i just bought this yesterday what
happened i'm like
i had lunch i heard you have a little
box of cereal and a half gallon milk in
a salad bowl that was like very good
until the rib of your mouth
just couldn't stand one more bite
i mean it's crazy with the cereals now
you're drinking like it's equivalent to
having like three coca-colas
for a couple bowls of cereal you know
it's crazy man
so so dude let's talk about surfing man
i got
are you out there with like where are
you right now
um i'm in california okay cool man i'm
in malibu
yeah nice dude and uh
like when's the last time you got on
some like serious big wave [ __ ]
uh about a week ago nice where
the last well that came in up north i
was up north in uh like oregon
washington area i was traveling up the
coast just
looking at some potential uh waves you
know
we're riding these hydrofoils right now
so
uh we're riding these hydrofoils and the
hydrofoils
are allowing us to ride waves a lot
earlier and kind of look at waves
differently so now we're starting to
kind of look for waves that are
potentially good for hydrofoiling which
aren't necessarily the ones that are
optimum for surfing and
most surf spots are kind of crowded so
it's opening it up i mean
i was in nazareth last february on the
giant swell there i tried to go to the
huge swell that they had in europe this
last
couple weeks but um because the french
we won't let the french in so the french
won't let us in one of those things i
got to the airport have my stuff and
they're like yeah sorry you have a
french passport i'm like yeah i don't
and
they're like oh you can't get on the
plane but um but no i'm i'm
i'm in pursuit uh i'm still in pursuit
so you know and and part of it is
because i'm doing it a different way i
i'm not i like the concept of doing
things you haven't done before i think
that's
interesting well for sure i think you
could take that a step further and say
that you like the concept of uh
introducing the world to new ways to do
things that have never been done
right like wasn't it wasn't toe-in
surfing like entirely your brainchild
yeah was it but it was it was my friend
you know i always i'm always
about credit and who's thing and whose
idea you know i was saying that there's
nothing new
it's just a new application of an old
idea and in a way
i mean i think i've been involved with
stand up i've been involved with foiling
we're involved with kiting
um you know i have some innovations in
fitness stuff i like
innovation i think it's good i mean part
of it is and you can relate to this
you know i i don't uh i don't mind if
people laugh at me
i'm i'm good with that like it works
it's cool like i don't care being a kook
i don't care about being a beginner
i know it's only temporary normally you
know if you do it right once you
probably won't be a beginner
so i'm good with that stuff i think
that's helpful that i think that helps
me
um try new things because i'm not like
hey this is what
i do and i only do this and i don't go
outside my you know i don't go outside
my
my uh my rails and i think that's
allowed me to kind of
uh i mean without towing there you know
places like nazareth which is
considered you know where the big waves
are being ridden right now
wouldn't be happening and the waves at
chopu and tahiti wouldn't have been
i mean the waves that have been ridden
because of that technique um
you know are far beyond anything that we
were even
you know right comprehended we couldn't
believe that they were possible so
so that's you know and i like that i
like that stuff i think that for me
that's
it it's it's a it's a pretty fulfilling
thing to be able to do that stuff you
know to be able to
to you know they say there's two kinds
of people one person fulfilled by
beating others and then another person's
fulfilled by accomplishing things
and a cr and creative people are
whatever those
those things are you can relate you've
done some [ __ ] that no one's done and it
feels good
not because no one's done it mostly
because you haven't but there is
something satisfying about
you know about accomplishing things even
if there is
you know off the wall as as they can be
i think there's a probably a good amount
of overlap between those two types too
um i remember at one point we were in
niagara falls
on tour and uh and
i just like and ended up like watching a
video about all of the various
people the like every single person who
deliberately went over niagara falls
yeah in a barrel or
yeah in a barrel there was a kayak there
was and i was struck by
how it seemed that the success rate for
people who really like sort of gave it
some thought and did a little bit of
homework
was pretty high and i all of a sudden
became consumed with the idea
of going over niagara falls and some
kind of contraption i was reaching out
to different
people who uh what was the they reached
out to somebody at jpl
yeah the nassau people like [ __ ] to
to make
and and i was just going down this
rabbit hole and then my buddy chris
pontius
just just ended it in one [ __ ]
sentence he said dude it's been done
because we don't do [ __ ] that's been
done dude
you know give it up and i think that was
his way of looking out for me
of course at the end of the day i'm
actually such a [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't
think i ever would have done it
i mean the first person to ever do that
was the girl who went over in a whiskey
barrel she was 65 years old she went
over in a [ __ ]
wooden wine barrel yeah and and
then i bet she drank it first probably
right
and said i have this it idea
like one of the least least prepared
people and
she comes out [ __ ] at the bottom and
she goes and she says oh
that that wasn't much fun i i ought not
do that again
yeah [ __ ] oh my god but yeah this is
that's like uh
the idea of doing stuff that's never
been done is really is really pretty
awesome
i mean when you wrote chopu and
it was in that documentary that you guys
did um i mean after you do something
like that i remember
i believe his name is derek was saying
that um
you know you were on the wagon for a
while and you had a beer that night
after you did that i mean
like are you i we were talking about
being depressed earlier but like
after you do something so [ __ ] crazy
like that
like it's kind of hard to move the
needle for a couple weeks after that
right when you're when you're coming
that close to death and
let me tell you something about death
defying acts
you don't wait two weeks for another one
you
ride wild all the time for life
forever and you'll wear a whoop strap on
your wrist
so that you know exactly what is going
on with your body what's a whoop strap
it's just the most sophisticated
awesomest
fitness tracking device out there and it
works
very simply with an app on your phone
and it tells you
exactly how much rest you're getting
what kind of rest you're getting
what kind of activities you're doing
what your heart rate variability is
i mean i'm telling you there's nothing
out there that will give you more
insight into your health and fitness
than a whoop strap and i love it man
i've been wearing it forever i don't
even ever take it off because the
battery slides right onto it to keep it
charged
i'm telling you if you haven't tried
this you're out of your mind
so let's get you over to whoop.com
that's
w-h-o-o-p dot
com and use the promo code stevo for 15
off at checkout telling you man if you
don't have your whoop strap on
you are blowing it now go to woop.com
use the promo code steven with 15
off at checkout and let's talk about
defying
death yeah i mean you know you get
post-traumatic i mean i think any time
that you're pushing the edge
and of any time you're right in the line
of like surviving or not
you you get post-traumatic but we i mean
we had already had
experience with that just from riding
giant surf in general you go out and
have giant waves at jaws and
you know you and then you come back and
then two days later you're
a little growly and then you're like and
you don't feel that good
and then you start becoming aware of it
and then you start
learning how to combat it and start
going okay well you know
after you do that don't indulge yourself
in things that are going to make you
more depressed
you know get a massage take go to sleep
early eat good
like start to like nurture the system to
help you recover but
but post you know post is a real thing
for for
anybody pushing uh the edge
whenever you feel like death is present
right so if you feel like hey
you know i could die right now and you
and you'll really understand you can and
you feel like
that death is there i mean you're going
to get a because everything's going to
go on
so the whole system is going to be at
max all your awareness
you know everything's going to be be
focused and
after you come down from that the body
goes oh now we're safe you're just gonna
be like
you know you're gonna you're gonna get
whacked from it so
i think there's another sort of
perspective on that though too
which is less about the the trauma of it
and
more about like the accomplishment of it
like say for example
i got i think that for olympic athletes
olympic hopefuls that the most
like terrible thing that can happen in
their life is to actually win the medal
you know because because in a sense when
they hang that metal around your neck
it's almost like this this just sense of
doom that they've just
hung the end of your life around your
neck that at this point now you've
peaked and the whole rest of your life
is going to be some [ __ ] downward
like
like that man on the wire documentary
like i think after that he did that
incredible
like high wire thing with the empire
state building or whatever the world
trade center and then like after that
like it's just shit's over and i think
that's what you're talking about more
than
the trump but you know what but i bet
there's another actually there and
there's something in line with what
you're saying
that's act there's a piece to that which
is
that you think you're gonna do that you
think when you do that all of a sudden
the world's going to be different then
it's the same freaking world
so it's part of it's that too right it's
like when i win that gold medal
it's going to just take care of all
these problems and then you're like
the day after you're like same problems
and you're like i didn't i mean i could
say
in my own uh career that i got to a
certain point where like i go hey listen
if i'm if i can ride these the biggest
waves the best and
that's gonna everything's gonna be cool
and it's gonna take care of it all then
you
and then you i mean whether you're doing
that or not you do what you think you
are or whether people see you or
whatever
but you get to a position where you're
like something's happening like
like what you want and then all of a
sudden you're like
whoops nothing happened you're like now
what
yeah it's like we were talking about
with logic where like you tell yourself
oh if i just
had this then i'd be happy or if i just
had a job or if i could just get abs
then i'd be happier if i could and then
you get those things or you get money or
you and then
you still it didn't fill the void like
you still want more than at that point
right
look at wealth wealth is probably the
greatest example of that people just if
i could just get a bunch of money
and then you see like wow most people
that have a lot of money
are miserable yeah right and the people
that are pursuing
trying to survive they don't have time
first of all to be miserable because
complaining is a luxury so if you have
enough time to sit around and complain
it's probably because
everything's taken care of so or at
least you're eating and you have a house
you know
but it is it is interesting that you
know that thing and then you have to go
i mean for me in my career it was like a
lot of it was like okay
aggression like fight your way in and
fight your way to the top and you know
and
and aggress aggress your way right and
then you get there and then you're like
okay now i'm here now what and then
you're like oh well i can't
keep you know brewing up that aggression
because i don't have it anymore
like i don't i i used it all to get here
and now i'm here and i'm like
now what then you're like well actually
no i really love doing this this is
great
so then you got to change your mind from
the mindset of aggressing to
pursue into i'll say now contentment
this is a new place to start from i'm
content and then but now i'm still want
to pursue so how do you
go from aggress and pursue to content
and pursue and then you realize hey if
you don't love it that's why your
intentions are everything why do you do
something
you got to love it like i love what i do
i love and i'll do it
until i die and i'll some form of it and
that's just
you know and that's and and i know that
and i'm good if no one sees me
and i just and only my friends and we go
we can do it in hiding
that's wonderful i'm i'm good i don't
need people going good job that was
great
i mean because i because i truly love it
and so
but along the way sometimes you wonder
you know when it becomes a job
then it's a little different then all of
a sudden it's not you're not doing it
when you want how you want pretty soon
you're having to go
okay i gotta show up here and do it and
deliver and you know expectations and
i mean it just becomes a whole another
you know a whole nother game
you know sure it's so crazy that when
i think when i was a kid i could safely
say that
there really wasn't any such thing as a
like an athletic career for athletes
over 30
or something right is that about fair to
say like oh
yeah you know like maybe
well like sport like you're older than
basketball if you're 34.
yeah like uh rock stars that
weren't over 30. you know like athletes
weren't over 30. now it's like
well [ __ ] dude look at the rolling
stones they're 75
you know and they're rocking yeah and
you know look at look at laird
so so so what's uh like
what do you think is the ceiling on
[ __ ] like action sports athletes
as far as age goes i mean i i listen
i think you know they did they did a
study about video games
and they said who's the best at video
games and they're like
well kids are and they're like actually
no kids aren't
adults are that are still excited
about video games and the problem is
when you get to be an adult
and you go through the thing pretty sure
you're not excited so how long can you
retain your enthusiasm you know
when we say retain your youthful
enthusiasm how long can you be stoked
and excited about it
that's the harder part i think that's
the part that that
that will come before maybe you are
physically
now maybe your stuff's not you know when
you get to be 50 60
70 your bones aren't as flexible and
you're not as loose and
you're not as fearless because you've
slapped the ground 80 more times than
everybody else and there's all these
other factors but all of that starts to
take away
the enthusiasm right the the you being
excited a little kid it's just like
i can't wait to do it they're just all
and they all the other guys like yeah
whatever i've done it i've seen it and
so i think it's more connected to that i
think that
most i think we we inhibit ourselves we
stop
ourselves sooner than actually we're
stopped everybody wants to be like oh i
could
you know they stopped me from doing it
no you stopped yourself you just decided
you didn't want to do it anymore so
i think that's the hardest part is to
retain being stoked right being
excited yeah laird is quoting the great
john cooper mellencamp
that the the the life goes on after the
thrill of living is gone
this is the sad truth man a little ditty
so
how how is your uh you know speaking of
you know smacking the ground have you
had a million surgeries like danny way
and travis pastrana and yeah i'm not i'm
not quite as
uh i had i probably had more stitches
than those guys that weren't surgery
because we
when we're in the cut game we get cut a
lot you know i mean i have a
i have a fake hip now and uh that was uh
that was probably the best surgery i've
ever had because it was i was awake
i walked out the thing was like in month
was crazy two months was like
i was bionic and and and so that but
i've had eight knee stuff
and you know like i said mostly a lot of
stitches and a lot of
you know and i've had a bunch of breaks
i'm not i'm not travis level like the
you know just smacking the ground every
time you turn around these guys are
breaking a bone
danny's the same way yeah you know
danny's uh
yeah danny the same kind of breaks but
i've had a ton of
you know i've had more than i can count
let's just put it that way i mean i
attribute
injury to really kind of fitness and
wellness and being healthy be more
understanding about what it takes to be
healthy
through injury because you know i look
at injuries like a form of failure and
you know you evaluate when you fail when
you succeed you don't evaluate if you
just keep winning
and never get hurt you never you never
really evaluate but when you lose
you like you're like hey what did i do
and when you break [ __ ]
you then you're really like what did i
do like what or what did i do wrong and
how do i get back to be strong and and
that that's where i think you
a lot of the you know that's where a lot
of the training comes in
lifestyle you start being concerned
about you know sleeping good
and eating good and training hard to
recover
but i've had i've been i've been hurt i
have my i've had my you know
i have my boards through the face and
split heads and
bones and compounds and i mean i've had
a you know i've had
all that i've had all that fun
i think uh i think that we arrived to
the conclusion that danny way
plus travis pastrana equals matt hoffman
oh yeah exactly well
it's the nature of the beast right
that's the right the game
matt hoffman's the most reconstructed
human being ever
crazy we gotta get him on here yeah i
know that you do workouts with like
where you're holding weights down at the
bottom of a pool or you're doing like a
lot of holding your breath
right you're and uh is that for [ __ ]
say that again i said we like suffering
we have a there's a thing about
suffering
yeah so how long can you hold your
breath and then are you doing that for
like big wave surfing in case you get
held down
and is there ever enough training for
that you know if you
take a wipe out on a 70-foot wave are
you just like [ __ ] i wish i would have
done that more when you're underneath
tumbling well you know that do you know
uh
you know who voice gracie is yeah oh
yeah a friend of mine
voiced the friend of ryan we were doing
an inter uh gabby was doing an interview
with him
and gabby and a woman said asshoys and
she said hey
you know what do you do when the guy has
you on the thing and then he's got you
in a lock and this and the thing and
hoist looked at her and just said well
you just don't ever get there
you never get that audition you know
what i mean like what do you do
to survive a 70-foot you know wipeout
you just don't don't wipe out
exactly don't make a mistake to begin
with but but uh
you know i mean i used to have a thing
where i said don't prepare for what you
don't want to have happen
because it's like a self-fulfilling
prophecy like you have all this
preparation to
be able to take a long hold down and all
of a sudden you're gonna have a long
hold down
but you know the the the training that
we do
i mean the fact is is that you you you
get the most benefit from your training
when you go to failure if you're a
weightlifter you go to
you can't lift you know you're a runner
you go to you can't run your swimmer you
go to you can't swim
and breath holding uh has a systemic of
a benefit on your body on your health
and so
it's all breath related it's all your
ability to absorb oxygen
from the air i mean there's a bunch of
cool cool stuff it and it's
uh you know and and being comfortable in
those
moments when you really need to breathe
right and
and and drowning is one of the you know
like four or five great kind of uh
i would say i call it dna fear you know
it's like this thing that's internal
like
drowning burning falling being eaten by
a giant animal
i mean these are kind of these are some
of the great motivators
these are the core fears right like
don't don't piss your wife off that kind
of stuff
but these are these are core core fears
and i think and drowning is
one of the you know one of the ones
that's really just built into us so
being underwater the body gets put into
these situations but
you know the nice thing about the water
for us and the training that we do is
it makes us better at the water like
being able to swim with
big dumbbells or hold your breath for
extended periods of time you know
i always say you know people go how long
have you can you hold your breath and it
goes well so far long enough
so so far i've been able to hold my
breath long enough um
you know and it's also about holding
your breath under load
because it's one thing to go hey i can
do you know we can do a wim hof
uh i can do a an apnea pranayama some
kind of breath work
i can you know you can load up and i can
hold my breath for five six
i can take in most anybody and get him
to do a five minute breath hold but
but when you're running from a giant dog
that's trying to bite you
you know and then you get to the end of
the fence how long can you hold your
breath and you know
20 seconds 30 seconds that's like that's
like eight you know that's
six seven minutes i mean an equivalent
so
you know holding your breath at maximum
heart rate i mean we train for that kind
of stuff
being able to swim with weights and deal
with that stuff it just helps you with
your
comfort in the but it's good for
everybody i mean i got
i get i get seals training up here i get
athletes i get
you know i got a just a a huge array of
people that come and train with us
because
it's good for everybody you know
everybody can benefit
fighters can benefit from it i get a
bunch of fighters that come
i get just a really broad group of
people
and there's no one that doesn't benefit
from the water training and then it's
and then it's
okay well now there's no impact and so
you can work harder and
you can you know it's like i got
basketball buddies that you know
end up jumping higher you know they've
been playing for 12 years in the league
and all of a sudden they're you know
they gain a couple inches on their
vertical
because of the volume of reps you can do
so there's a bunch of stuff
um in the training and and you know
we use in the training we just do the
same thing that we do with everything we
just kind of
are exploratory we just play with stuff
and get ideas and
you know and and try to be innovative
make it i mean listen the truth is i get
bored easily and just
you know you tell me to swim laps in a
pool
you know i'm gonna it's just gonna be
like it's gonna be like the orca with
the floppy fin i'm gonna be over there
you know i could eat a trainer or
something but you know if you say hey
get this dumbbell and swim it over there
and then when you get there jump up and
down a few times and
you know and and i mean gabby and i did
a drill yesterday where we were doing
these things called gorillas where you
have two dumbbells and you do like a
it's almost like a squat press jump
thing and then and then we do that
do as many as you can on one breath hold
and then swing back and forth just
i mean it's it's it's uh it all it's
working you know it
it it works it's it's uh and it's
beneficial for everybody but it
definitely does
affect uh the way you are in the water
your comfort when you're
you know if a giant if you do make a
mistake and you're at the bottom of the
ocean
you have a comfort of being okay there
because you're
you've been there before um you're not
gonna panic
you know you're good with it do you have
a
like as part as part of being healthy
like uh
like meditation practice yoga like
spiritual stuff
well i mean i do breath work you know i
do i do i do
i do breath work you know some of that's
meditation most of my meditation is more
active
so it's more like active i mean i i i'm
i'm more into flow state when you think
about
my spiritual practice it's flow state my
relationship with nature
i mean i have a pretty intense
relationship with you
i talk to the hawks they talk to me you
know and i'm here the hawks are circling
we're communicating i come on the
morning the hawk standing on the pole
looking at me i look at him i go hey
good morning
i have no trouble believing that yeah
you know but but uh
you know i i think that that's uh the
extent of my spirituality has a lot to
do with my relationship with nature
like my my time in the ocean my just my
my awareness of of of nature and and
being in it
and you know and and and the sun i do
solar gazing in the morning
a lot of times in the evening i'm you
know i'm breath work it's just all part
of
you know and i think the heat the ice
all that stuff
is in there is in that practice i think
it's kind of yeah
included you ever gotten in the ice with
wim hof
absolutely absolutely yeah women i are
like women i are like
this you know women i i've had i had
whim over in the early days when i first
started icing
uh it was funny because i was reading
the iceman the book the iceman and then
one day like wim hof comes over and i go
oh gab wim hof is coming over and she's
like
wim hof the guy you're reading about the
book yeah he's on his way over she's
like
are you crazy so yeah whim came and
women i
uh you know i got women in the pool and
do some doing some swimming and
and uh started playing in the ice a
little bit and did some breath work with
whim that was great
that was that was nice i've been you
know i really
appreciate breath work i think breath
work is probably where
you're gonna get some of the most in
kind of powerful spiritual
transformations you're going to get some
you're going to definitely breath in
spirit i think breath and spirit are
are together obviously when you're a
baby cries
takes its first breath i think the
spirit possesses him and
normally in normal death when you stop
breathing the spirit leaves
and when people have out of bodies and
stuff i think it's
related to breath so breath work works
for meditation and
and your spirituality as well are you
into yoga
yeah i've done yoga over the years i
kind of dabble in it
and like lately my routine i probably
haven't done enough
of yoga but i do i do yoga like i said i
just
i kind of have a tendency to kind of go
through
moments like i'm into yoga and then i'm
into you know some other kind of cardio
stuff
and you know i'm just doing different
practices at different times
how about cycling huh how about a
bicycle
bicycle yeah i do stand up so i have a
bike
uh bicycles without seats and you stand
on them and then we just do hill climbs
and stuff
just just because the posture the biking
posture is pretty hard on you
so there's a bike called an elliptigo
you can see them they don't have their
seatless
yeah and uh and we stand on them they're
they're harder and
you and you got better uh posture but i
listen i did the race across america
i've done a bunch of brutal bike uh long
distance bike stuff
and uh i just posture's hard on you
the positioning's hard on the bike are
people are people studying you
like scientifically like do you check in
like blood work once a month
the mental ward i go to the mental head
no but i mean like you're doing
all this incredible stuff for your
physical fitness like is anyone kind of
checking in monthly or yearly like blood
work or anything like that
to sort of research blood work i just
went and just did a pretty elaborate
heart thing just because
a friend of mine who's an incredible
physician just said hey you know
i'm 56 he's like oh you know what
normally at 55 guys go and just
look at their heart and i'm like sure
i'll go and so i went and i i did two
days of
of heart assessment and uh you know we
did everything they did every single
different you know eco caico
geekolico every different one they could
you know
they could do on me and some stress
stuff and a bunch of stuff and uh
and then the doctor just said yeah he
goes i don't know what you're doing but
just
keep doing whatever you're doing good
to hear joe rogan uh describe you
is that it's like he's talking about a
superhero it's it's
pretty awesome yeah he's he's generous
he's
generous you know i listen i'm like
everybody else i think it's a
it's just a matter of uh you know
i think it's just a habit you know
that's creating habits it's just
what do you want to do and you know i
know that
unless unless i'm moving consistently
i'm just not
i'm not as good a person as i can be i'm
a better person
when i do these things i'm just better
for my family i'm better for my friends
i'm better for myself
yeah food tastes better you know
everything's better
everything's just better when i do it
and when i don't and so
you know i i that's how i you know and
and i have a tendency to
just ramp stuff like hey if 200 is good
then 220 is good and if 220 is good then
240's and
if 240 is great you know i just sent joe
a video just
the other day because we were laughing
on the sauna we got this one dial and
the one we have only goes to 250 and i
sent him one a couple months ago he's
like oh yeah
you know the problem with this dial it
only goes to 250. so then i found a new
dial that goes to 270 and so i got the
thing to 270
and i'm like yeah now we're at two sets
how long are you staying in there for
free i don't know
always more is better but it's that
seems to be my
you know that's my thing like hey if a 5
foot weight's good then a 10 foot waves
got to be better and if a 10-foot wave's
good then it's got to be
you know my dad raised me with the motto
if a little is good a lot better
there's always that that's my approach
with your creamer it depends on what
you're talking about actually but
right you know you yeah is there
anything you do on a daily basis like a
routine that you have to do like are
there five things you're like
[ __ ] i'm off if i don't do that yeah put
the dishes away
then you're in trouble no no no just for
my own mindset
oh really like yeah in the morning
like i i you know i i mean i have a
couple little routine
like habitual things i do i always like
super
hot showers like first thing in the
morning when i first thing i do is just
get into a super
probably the fish in me you don't need
to wet the gills um
but i i really uh
putting the dishes away is a big thing
like if there's no dish to put away i
kind of feel like
i feel off you know like the night
before all the dinner stuff i'll just
i'll put everything away because it's
it's task completion
you know there's there's a task
completion you know i heard a military
you probably heard the speech from the
general talking about how you know why
the military guys make their beds
and it's you know yeah i heard that idea
and it's all about task completion
so that you've done one thing and
completed it and it allows you to go on
and so there's something about that that
i like there's certain things that i do
um that i that are task completion like
you just gone through you did it
and then it's like okay now i've done
that and that that kind of sets you up
to complete other tasks
and so that's a piece of it you know
there's an organization
an organization that i like uh to
to do and it's a little ritualistic you
know it's a little ritual
yeah it's like and i like and i like
[ __ ] to be in the right place too it's
like okay
that way you know it's everything's in
its right spot it makes perfect sense
what you just said though cause like if
i have a day where like
i'm like gonna run in the morning but
then i talk myself out of it when i wake
up that whole day like
i'm not getting anything done because
i'm just then you're gonna be mad at
yourself then you're gonna be like well
who am i that i can't my mom said one
thing to me and i and that's probably
one of the greatest things that she ever
said
amongst all the great things she said to
me but she said if you can't be true to
yourself you can't be true to anybody
else
and there's nothing like telling
yourself hey yeah i'm going to go for a
run then you get up you don't do it then
yeah ah and that's happening you just
stuck you're like i
suck yeah yeah this is a shame
yeah i got to tell myself i did that
last night i was going to go on a bike
ride
we did it and i [ __ ] didn't you
bought all the stuff for a bike ride but
you didn't go on a bike ride
yeah dude it's the worst he said do you
have uh
do you have any animals yeah yeah i got
a pup
i gotta i gotta i got uh my my i have uh
i have i've always had male dogs with
bowls
nice i have male dogs with balls and uh
i know people talk about hey what are
they for and i'm like you know
it's good for the ligaments that's what
my friend told me he's a he's a doctor
he goes yeah the dogs
when they they retain their testicles
it's good for their ligaments that's the
ligaments and the it makes sense that
the balls would be connected to the
ligaments but
uh but yeah i know i've had i grew up
around dogs i grew up around hunting
dogs and we always had a pet i had a pet
dog when i was a little kid
and i've had rhodesian ridgebacks were
my favorite for a long time
uh and then i had combo rhodesian
rottweiler mixes and now i've the latest
breed the last two dogs i have i have
these rat carriers and uh the rat
terrors are pretty amazing
uh dogs but yeah man you know we've been
with dogs for thirty thousand years we
have a dude the relationship that we
have
you know they say our brains change and
their brains change because they didn't
have to hunt as well
and we didn't have to be as aware so you
know we
are if anybody doesn't like dogs i'm
always a little i always kind of
side-eye them i'm like hey what's this
guy
what's this guys that's true yeah
we have we have a type of dog that we
like it's it's a street
dog yeah yeah well in hawaii poi dog
yeah in hawaii it's the poi dog which
means it's just mixed
every different kind of my own one yeah
for sure
do you have uh i mean of course you've
got the superfood creamer but do you
have like
other product lines that that uh
i might not be aware of you mean the
superfood stuff well i have xpt which is
my which is our like
our health and wellness like a fitness
brand that we have
all kinds of apps but but in superfood
yeah we have a whole like daily ritual
so we have this thing of daily ritual
which is like
wake up in the morning get hydrated then
have your coffee and your creamers then
we have like soup
other other products we have an
incredible uh
plant-based protein powder right now
that's just no indigestion or anything
from it
and then we have like a before the bed
go to sleep at night stuff so we have a
whole
you know and a bunch of other ones we
have about 35 or 40
uh uh about about 30 right now 30
something
skews in in superfood so so what's the
official website to find
all of that it's a lyric superfood
learnsuperfood.com
they have everything it's all there and
then like you said cbs and
we have a we have uh right now we have
we've launched a new liquid
we have a line of liquid creamers that
we launched in
uh whole foods global so it's
every whole food every whole foods has
it right now and then sprouts i think is
also carrying it a couple others
so the liquids actually i mean that's
yeah that stuff's
not even legal it's it's crazy that
stuff's good but
but the uh but i'm i'm i'm i'm the
powder i've been on the you know i use
this stuff
i can't i can't have enough of it i mean
i was like every i'm out every week i'm
like how come there were the cupboards
out it's like
but yeah the uh but i like the turmeric
i'm
a lover of tumeric because it's uh you
know it's the uh
i like i like the flavor but it's also i
know it's anti-inflammatory
so super good for it's good i like the
the flavor of the turmeric but you gotta
be extra careful because if you spill it
on the counter
that goes yeah yeah it's over
there it's okay if your couch if your
counter is orange it's cool
like if orange counter it's no right and
i got i
have a bone to pick with cvs
because they never have the cacao flavor
yeah
cow flavor is the best [ __ ] flavor
yeah they gotta get their act together
man and stock that well
yeah you just might have to bypass and
send you a case so
yeah yeah i get mine on amazon okay
amazon's got everything
all right well there you go what did you
talk about promoting lyric [ __ ] i love
it man
for sure it's the best i was like a
black coffee purist like elitist i was
like if someone put cream in their
coffee i sort of judged them
but now your coffee or your creamer like
i can't
my coffee doesn't taste right without it
i really mean that like it's so good
well i i have some i have some news we
just had a late uh one of our lea
kind of latest innovation is that we
because i know that there's
uh cough you know black coffee lovers
and so we have some infused
grounds that we're doing that have uh
like for focus
a focus one and we have the we have a
mushroom infused one so you can still
drink your black one but
i have a feeling once you use the
creamer it's it doesn't want it anymore
you don't realize there's a whole thing
about the the way you absorb the
caffeine because of the fat so there's a
whole there's it's actually
all the products are all function based
so there's a function behind
every one of them it's not just like
yeah this tastes great and have it
there's actually functional
aspects to the products and so yeah you
know the great thing is i think
after being an athlete and being
sponsored for you know i mean i
listen i my first kind of relationship
with being sponsored and stuff was when
i was 16 so you're looking at
you know you're looking at 40 years of
you know sponsors and when
when the industries were up and when the
industries were down and which brands
and what what products will you align
yourself with
you know all of that stuff um and you
know
it's amazing and the evolution i was
like one day it'd be nice to
you know be your own sponsor right that
would be the apex yeah
i mean would be but the truth is is that
of all i mean
the fact is is that it i it feels
unbelievably great because
i know what these products are and i'm
not it's not like
hey drink this crash trash but it's
super good you'll love it
like because they're paying you kind of
thing i don't it's not and that's uh
that's the
you know that's why i have it's like i
have a remorseless drive to promote
the stuff because i know it's unreal
it's the stuff's awesome i use it every
day and so it's like
you know what i mean i'm just saying
like you know you can relate to that
like hey
you know it's like because there's a lot
of times you got to do stuff in here
to survive where you're going hey you
know what use this or try
this and you're kind of like yeah that
stuff i don't know like energy drink
sponsors
you know oh my god yeah like i feel bad
even
asking i'm not even saying a name a lot
of athletes
energy drink sponsors exactly you know
i mean so i've asked i've asked various
people who are sponsored by energy
drinks be like dude
you know i get that it's on your helmet
it's on your board whatever you know but
like
people like you don't [ __ ] actually
drink that [ __ ] dude what are you
drinking four of these a day you'll
[ __ ]
die and uh there was one there's one guy
who said no dude i [ __ ] drink it
and he's not like a young guy yeah he's
not not even a young guy and i thought
dude that's great man there's there's
integrity in that
i think that we've been uh pretty pretty
like i'm proud to say that for the stuff
that we promote like on the podcast and
just in general
we line ourselves with like there's
nothing i promote that i don't stand by
that i don't use
yeah i have laird i have uh the
superfood creamer in my car and i just
take key bumps as i'm going to my next
destination
meanwhile paul's over here saying ah
black coffee i'm over it
but but i'll put your layered creamer
into your layered infused
blend
but you know what but you would say you
know it's interesting though when you
talk about it too because i
and i because i throughout you know
throughout your in in listen sometimes
you know you just got to do what you got
to do to survive but i always used to
say you know
when you can say no it doesn't mean as
much as when you can't say no
right no it's like when you can't say no
and you say no
that that this is a little more powerful
it's like later on when you could say no
then it's like oh yeah i don't do
that and and in a way i think i think
that it's a uh
i think it's a responsibility and
unfortunately you see it a lot in
professional sports and stuff you see
like these guys promoting stuff and
you're like yeah you know
that's giving a lot of people diabetes
buddy like
did you make enough money already do you
have to like tell them to eat that
and then you know and and you have a
responsibility like
people are looking up to you you know
and kids are looking up to you and
they're looking at you like hey you're
the guy
and you're saying yeah just have a
little more of that poison it's going to
make you great
you're like i don't know i just think
there's some sort of karmic bill
on that for me in my in my world in my
world that i live in
i just feel like yeah you know what
maybe not now but at some point you're
going to have to
walk up to the big guy and be like
[Laughter]
right take your punishment i did i love
that man
lyrics really got me rethinking this
offer to be the next girl
colonel sanders
all the people who dress up as colonel
sanders it's like oh god dude [ __ ]
poor bastard
that's so funny i got a question this is
pivoting a little bit
but uh i just watched the david
attenborough documentary about how much
the
the climate in the world has changed in
his lifetime and you being a guy so in
touch with nature and you've spent so
much time in the ocean
how have you personally seen or have you
seen the ocean
change in your lifetime and in what ways
well i i mean i think the whole world
you know that that it's impossible
if you're at all observant uh
to to deny the fact that the weather is
just not
acting like it right mother nature
normally
does given our short little you know
time span of of observing i mean just
the way
the size of the hurricanes the size of
the droughts the
the length of periods of no rain the
length of periods of rain i mean just
fire
the stuff that's going on i mean the
surf our surf and the way the surf is
i mean the amount of you know the the
amount of garbage in the ocean in places
the you know the the the dirtiness of
the ocean the lack of
you know the the lack of fish uh you
know
and just just all of those the all those
factors uh
are being you know there's it's it it's
happening
it's happening right right in front of
us and and
and you know there's not a lot that it
seems like we can
we can do about it i mean in a way this
this thing that we've just been going
through this pandemic
this corona this thing is you know given
the earth
probably the the biggest chance to get a
breath
that it's had in the last hundred years
i mean it's for sure
you know and i mean i think there's been
people have seen results of that people
have looked around and had they've seen
like wow
the you know certain things are just
making a comeback just just
because they had you know eight months
or six months and just
a few less you know jet planes or
a few less boats or a few this you know
less something
but yeah i mean yeah it's it's uh
i mean that we're definitely going
through uh we're going through
some i mean not i mean obviously we're
going through it you know because of
what's going on right now but
but the earth is going through you know
i always say i i tell people i go yeah
the earth is sick
it's got a it's got a uh you know it's
got a
an illness it's called humans yeah
that's
for sure you know that's the unfortunate
truth and i don't see it i don't see a
an obvious i think there's small ways
that we're all trying to attempt to
to make a difference but i i think that
you know
when you see the just the volume can't
handle this amount of p
i mean we just have too many people
there's just too many people and too
much
need to you know but paul
asked what was really sounded like a
great
and and and just inspiring question
and laird's answer was you don't have to
be a superhuman
who spent his whole life in the ocean to
see the obvious
like the world is [ __ ] like anybody
anybody can tell you the world is [ __ ]
yeah definitely definitely unfortunately
that's that was
yeah but being a big wave guys do the
hurricanes help a little bit yeah are
there bigger waves
sometimes because of all this crazy
weather we're category fives right which
is pretty good for nazareth
yeah yeah i mean we're you know
obviously we're getting but we're
getting real sporadic stuff too we're
getting like
a big one and then nothing for months on
end so
we're not necessarily getting uh lately
i mean we're in
la nina right now which means that the
jet stream isn't
like right over the pacific so that so
we're getting like
it's a terrible uh north pacific season
thus far uh the atlantic is getting some
freaky
big ones but you know these these these
these big
radical storms i mean these are these
are signs of like be careful like we're
gonna get we can you know
we get the right situation and you know
it's gonna shut
things down i mean this is you know you
get some heavy-duty
you know you get the if that current
stops in the atlantic all of a sudden
you know
france goes into the europe goes into an
ice age i mean it just
didn't and this stuff happens can happen
quick given
how quickly the the weather's changing
but yeah well there'll be some giant
ones i mean
you know and the selfish side of it but
then there's also like i said
like we're going through one of the
flattest seasons that we've experienced
in the north pacific
you know this year but yeah sure and i'm
just
joking about that being a good it's not
a benefit you know yeah
i mean hey dude take it where you can
get it
yeah take it takes the silver lining
well [ __ ] hey man right on dude i
think
uh i i don't have any more questions i
had one last one
um and then you have everything dialed
in it seems like you know you got
your the health the spirituality the in
and beforehand gabby answered the zoom
and then you guys had a really good
communication you know she was calling
what's the key to like a successful
long-term marriage well they they did a
study of ten thousand couples
and uh and there was only one consistent
factor that
that and and people can agree or
disagree but compromise that's
the facts but they did they did a study
and it didn't matter what the dynamic
was
man woman bread holder this thing just
all that they had every different
scenario you could think of
but the one consistent thing was that
the man respected the woman
um i have a lot of respect for gabby um
i
have i grew up with an incredible mother
um
that allowed me to be highly respectful
of women
um i can i can i'm good with gabby's
being a powerful woman i'm good with her
i mean
she wants to conquer the world i'll be
right there cool you know taking
uh clearing the path um for her so i'm
super supportive on her
she's super supportive on me uh and
my pursuits uh sometimes beyond even my
own
kind of capacity to understand she's
like yeah i think you need to go
and ride a wave somewhere um so there's
that and
and and and for me honestly it's a
little bit like a cold war you know
we both have nukes we know that it's
gonna be bad for everybody if we drop
them
and it's no one's going to win and it's
a if she shoots hers
he's probably in the fallout it's going
to take her out if i shoot mine's going
to take me out
just like a it's just a lost loss like
lost so we just don't even go there
and uh right now we're we're trying to
survive the girls the girls are
uh you know the girls are more than a
challenge for
for both of us uh our daughters but but
the truth is
you know that we it's our each of our
own responsibility to be happy
so i you know you go get happy
all go get happy and then we'll come
back and we'll be happy together but
don't rely on me to behave in a way or
do things to make you happy because
i can barely make myself happy how am i
going to be able to make you happy
and vice versa so you know we we the two
individuals becoming whole can be
together but
if you're looking for people to you know
if you're looking for a partner to
complete you
i go then you're putting unrealistic
expectations and then there's just no
there's that's gonna fail at some point
that's gonna because you're never gonna
be able to keep up with that you're
never gonna be able to
do everything and be everything you know
and and for me on my side
you know i mean i i'm uh
you know i mean gabby you know gabby
told me once you know no one's above
survival
right right she and she looked straight
at me like and i'm like
i guess that means me like she's steamed
like no one is above smile you mean me
like are you talking yeah you're talking
to me okay
so i'm not about so if it's survival or
you i'm surviving and you're not
so i'm like i got that but the uh but
also too
you know i think that it's in our
relationship
and you know because there's so many
different dynamics i think it's
important for
people to assume their roles you know
it's like and and there could be
you know a man and woman can be together
and the woman can be the man and the man
can be the woman and a woman and woman
can be together and a man can one can
you know everybody can be the thing but
there's got to be a male and a female
dynamic in that because that's what
works right so and it's like
you know i'm the one that like if
there's some thing outside and it's
dangerous
you probably send me out there and if
the toilet breaks and there's
crap everywhere you send me in there
like i'm this is there's certain certain
things that i'm good at
that you call me in like if there's a
fire you i put the suit on and they
go away and they're safe and i'm gonna
fight the buyer it's like that's what we
do
yeah so and i think that that's a uh you
know
and her you know making the house and
making sure everything
and the details that's her she excels at
that and
she assumes that role so we assume our
roles that that make it possible and i
think that's you know
that's that's why we've survived thus
far let's just put that we're going on
25 years so we have 25 years coming up
on uh the 30th of this month i better
remember that day
congratulations yeah it's so rad man
well [ __ ] hey dude thank you larry i
uh thank you
i just maybe we'll get to see in person
sometimes maybe we can get together yeah
i'll get you to come over and train
i'll get you to come into the deep end
dumbbells
i love that i i stubbed baptism
you know
thank you so much aloha man
what a rad bro and what a legend
now those of you who are watching this
on youtube
seeing this amazing background
gotta be wondering where the hell are
they what are they doing
and i told you it's a secret
only for the people who stick around to
the end of the podcast
because you know i love you so much i'll
tell you a little bit
we're in utah and we're on this crazy
mission
driving around giving tattoos
okay and i'm not telling you anymore
because it's a secret
yeah dude thank you guys for listening
and watching
whatever
you